Congressman Randy Fine caused an uproar
on X when he posted, "If they force us
to choose, the choice between dogs and
Muslims is not a difficult one." He was
reacting to a post by Zoran Mandani
superfan Nerdin Kiswani who proclaimed,
"Finally, New York City is coming to
Islam. Dogs definitely have a place in
society, just not as indoor pets. Like
we've said all along, they are unclean.
Congressman Fine pointed out the
context. For context, this is the leader
of one of the key mainstream Muslim
groups that supported Mamani.
Now, taken by itself, Congressman finds
Post is open to a range of different
interpretations. On one end of the
spectrum, critics are saying that he's
dehumanizing Muslims and that
dehumanization leads to really bad
things. For instance, former first
minister of Scotland, Humza Ysef
replied, "After every uh-oh, G-word, we
ask the same question. How can people
inflict such cruelty on their fellow
human beings? The root cause is always
the same because society allowed the
dehumanization
of an entire people." Randy Fine is a
prime example of how that happens.
awful. Journalist Halaj Jabber adds,
"When elected officials compare human
beings to animals, they're not being
edgy. You're openly normalizing
dehumanization.
It is collective hatred directed at 1.9
billion people based solely on religion.
That kind of language has a long and
dangerous history. Dehumanization is
almost always the first step before
discrimination, exclusion, and violence
become easier to justify.
I find it fascinating that so many
people recognize the danger of
dehumanizing Muslims by comparing them
to animals given what the Quran says in
passages like surah 7 verse 179 where
Allah declares and surely we have
created many of the jin and mankind for
hell. They have hearts wherewith they
understand not, and they have eyes
wherewith they see not, and they have
ears wherewith they hear not the truth.
They are like cattle. Nay, even more
astray, those they are the heedless
ones. So non-Muslims are like cattle.
That's the Quran comparing non-Muslims
to cattle. But notice, non-Muslims are
even more astray. We're worse than
cattle. As the Quran states in Surah
98:6,
"Verily, those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran, and
Prophet Muhammad, from among the people
of the scripture, Jews and Christians,
and al- Mushrakun, Mushrakun are people
who associate partners with Allah, will
abide in the fire of hell. They are the
worst of creatures. So, Jews,
Christians, and other non-Muslims are
actually lower than cattle. We're lower
than dogs. We're lower than pigs. We're
the worst of creatures.
Sounds like the Quran is dehumanizing
non-Muslims.
I sure hope this never leads to violence
against non-Muslims.
But just so everyone knows my position,
for those who interpret congressman fine
as claiming that a dog is more valuable
than a Muslim, if I were in a burning
building and I only had time to rescue
either a dog or a Muslim girl, I would
rescue the Muslim girl 100% of the time.
And interestingly enough, any good dog
would agree with me. A good dog will lay
down its life to protect a human being,
which is why the hatred for dogs in
Islam seems so strange to so many of us.
But was Congressman Fine saying anything
about Muslims being like dogs? No. He
was saying that if the people we're
bringing in from other countries are
going to demand that we get rid of dogs,
they should just live in countries where
people don't keep dogs as pets. So I
made a simple statement. If I have to
choose between having my dog and you
living here and taking my dog away, the
choice isn't hard. You can leave and go
home. And what's fascinating is all the
Democrats that have attacked me, not a
single one has said you have the right
to own a dock. They are all coming down
on you can lead your dog to slaughter if
that's what we have to do to make Muslim
immigrants happy in the United States.
So, do you agree with Congressman Fine?
If the US government is bringing in
people who hate dogs and may eventually
demand that dogs be banned, should we
tell such people to find another country
to live in? Some of you may not
understand why there's even an issue
here because lots of people don't know
what Islam teaches about dogs. So, let's
look at what Muhammad taught. Sunnisai
Iban a Sabak said my told me that
Gabriel supposedly the angel Gabriel
peace be upon him said to the messenger
of Allah we angels do not enter a house
in which there is a dog or a picture the
next day the messenger of Allah
commanded that all dogs be ended even
small dogs I'm not sure how sensitive
the algorithm is going to be with talk
of doing something to dogs. So, I'll use
the word end to be on the safe side. So,
Jabriel told Muhammad that angels don't
like dogs or pictures. In response,
Muhammad ordered his followers to end
all dogs, even cute little dogs. Sah
Muslim 38:11 Allah's messenger ordered
the ending of dogs and we would send men
in Medina and its corners and we did not
spare any dog that we did not end. So
much so that we ended the dog that
accompanied the wet she camel belonging
to the people of the desert. But some of
Muhammad's companions complained saying
they need dogs for hunting and hurting.
So Muhammad modified his position on
dogs. Sunn Andasai 4279.
It was narrated from Iban Umar that the
messenger of Allah commanded that all
dogs be ended except dogs used for
hunting or hering livestock. He also
said that black dogs have to be ended
because black dogs are devils.
Pretty racist.
So people are allowed to have dogs for
hunting or for hering. But there's no
concept in Islam of having a dog that
lives with you in your house as a pet.
Now we can all understand the post from
Nerdin Kiswani that led to this recent
conflict. Finally, New York City is
coming to Islam. Dogs definitely have a
place in society, just not as indoor
pets. Like we've said all along, they
are unclean.
Like it or not, Islam has a problem with
dogs. And even converts to Islam pick up
on the hostility pretty quickly. As we
can see from Sneo's anti-dog rant.
Your dog
your dog. I don't care. It's not cute.
It's not It's I don't want to pet it. I
don't want to touch your dog. Dogs are
haram for a reason. And this was a sign
from Allah. Dogs are gross. Have a
child.
God wants us to have kids, not to have a
bunch of dogs.
Do dogs.
So, what do you dog lovers think? Is
Islam right about dogs? Are you willing
to give up your dogs to avoid offending
the perpetually offended?
Let me know what you think in the
comments. And let me ask you Muslims who
are watching,
do you really believe that black dogs
are devils? If so, tell us why you think
your prophet was right about black dogs.
Let me guess. Because he's Muhammad and
we mindlessly accept anything he says,
even if it makes absolutely no sense.
That is what you're about to say, wasn't
it?
That [music] cried on that. You proud on
that. You just backfired on me. You
pride on that. You pride on that. You
pride on that. You just backfire [music]
on me. This is a powerful religion.
There's a reason to it. Yeah. Yeah.
Here.